welcome to the man of Recaps this is the
complete Fast and Furious recap before
number 10 fast X it all started with the
Fast and the Furious at the underground
street racing scene in La the new kid in
town is Brian O'Connor here to make a
name for himself by challenging the
Undisputed King of the Road Vin Diesel
Dominic Toretto he puts his car on the
line yeah they're Racing for slips vroom
vroom car racing time but these races
always come down to hitting the NOS
button to get a super boost wow but
Brian's a buster who hit it too early
Vin Diesel waits till the right moment
and how he wins but when the cops show
up it's Brian who gives Dom a ride out
of there so he's welcomed into the crew
if you're playing the drinking game at
home have a Corona every time they do
but Brian O'Connor has a secret he's
working undercover with the feds yes a
team of precision drivers and souped
upon the Civics have been hijacking
delivery trucks and stealing high-end
Electronics they think it's Toretto so
they sent Brian in to befriend him and
find proof so Brian needs the crew
including Michelle Rodriguez Tom's
girlfriend Letty in fact Brian starts
dating Dom's sister Mia when he orders a
tuna sandwich but out of dreidel
Backyard Barbecue Brian befriends Dom
for real he really respects him for his
Devotion to family and general life
Outlook I live my life a quarter mile at
a time and on the final heist things go
bad this guy's shot the only way they
can save him is if Brian calls in a
police medical Chopper Brian being a cop
throws a wrench in their best friendship
but it comes down to a final gentleman's
race Dom pops a wheelie in his muscle
car and they finish just ahead of the
speed and train but epic wipe out dumps
cars totaled uh don't worry though he's
totally unscathed but now with the cops
closing in Brian gives his keys to
Toretto I owe you a 10 second car oh a
beautiful Bromance as Brian chooses
friendship over the law next up is Too
Fast Too Furious there's no Vin Diesel
we just follow Brian O'Connor who's
moved to Miami to be a street racer for
real Ludacris plays tennis who runs the
races down here and oh yeah vroom vroom
jump in the bridge the action is kicked
up a notch but one day the feds pick
Brian up because the drug dealers
recruiting drivers they want to send
Brian in undercover again Brian needs a
partner and with no Vin Diesel he
recruits his old best friend Tyrese as
Roman Pierce they also work with Eva
Mendes undercover as the judge dealer's
girlfriend and she and Brian start
flirting eyes on the road so Brian and
Roman transporting the drug money they
find a way to ditch his Goons ejectocito
does but the drug dealers one step ahead
he's going to escape on his yacht so
Brian's got to race a yacht but a Yachts
no match for a good old-fashioned
American muscle oh leaps the car into
the yacht Brian's back on the right side
of the law but he and Roman did pocket a
bunch of the cash number three is the
Fast and the Furious Tokyo Drift which
features none of the old cast they were
gonna make it an anthology Series so
meet Sean a good Southern boy who's an
excellent racer except for one thing he
can't really turn Sean moves to Tokyo
where he befriends Lil Bow Wow he tries
to join the underground street racing
scene here but there's a problem they're
into drifting so all they do is turn but
Sean's not scared he immediately
challenges the top dog here DK drift
King this nice guy Han takes pity on
Sean and lends him a car uh which Sean
immediately totals but Han takes this
kid under his wing and teaches him the
ancient art of drifting yeah pretty soon
Sean's a drift Master but there's beef
with the bad guy and it turns into a
race through the streets whoa drift
through the whole crowd and oh no
Honey's hit boom exploded Han dies at
least for now more on this later number
four is just Fast and Furious they lost
the does but brought back the old fast
yes it's a series reboot in fact Han is
part of their crew yeah this takes place
before Tokyo Drift they've moved on from
stealing DVD players to hijacking fuel
trucks and the actions kicked up another
notch when the law is closing in Dom
leaves Letty to protect her but then he
gets word from America that lady was
killed at least for now we'll come back
to that later she was killed while
driving for this drug dealer Braga who
FBI agent Brian O'Connor is going
undercover to investigate so Dom and
Brian both infiltrating braga's crew
drinking Coronas like old times they
team up with Broca's girlfriend Giselle
played by Gal Gadot it's a big race to
the Border where they kill the guy that
killed Letty and get Braga to U.S soil
but Brian's badly injured and with the
feds closing in it's the opposite of
fast one Dominic Toretto lets himself
get arrested to stay with his best
friend Brian but as Dom's being
transferred yeah Brian O'Connor leads
his friends to bust him out of there so
now in Fast Five breaking Dom off the
prison bus makes Brian a criminal for
real so they all go down to Brazil now
they're stealing expensive cars off of
trains and the actions kicked up another
notch but hunting them down is the rock
as special agent Hobbs and also a
Brazilian cop Elena who when Dom saves
her life they start flirting Brian and
Mia are still together in fact she's
pregnant and it's about this time the
series becomes all about family I don't
have friends
I got family they're gonna do one less
job but they need help so they assemble
a team Ocean's 11 style yes it's a heist
movie now they bring back Roman and tej
Han and Gisele uh plus these two guys
who only speak Spanish so I didn't quite
catch their names they steal this drug
dealer safe by attaching it to their
cars and driving it through the streets
oh epic they end up saving hobb's life
so he's like all right you guys can go
but you gotta leave the cash but this
safe's empty yeah earlier they swapped
them and now our crew is filthy rich
they retire to a country with no
extradition and live happily ever after
until furious six the whole gang's
happily retired Brian and Mia Dom and
Elena Han and Gisele fell in love eyes
on the road tejan Roman also together
all the time as a best friend comedy duo
but one day Hobbes shakes things up with
the news that Letty is alive she's
working for a bad guy Owen Shaw and if
the gang helps take him down pardons all
around but Shaw's not just some drug
dealer he's like a full-on super villain
who's gonna destroy the world so our
little family of Street Racers have
become full-on Mission Impossible super
spies when Dom tracks down Letty oh she
shoots him yeah she's got the Amnesia so
Dom has to win her heart again the way
he did the first time by beating her
industry race so shall steals some super
weapon or whatever and he's transporting
it in a tank but a tank's no match for a
good old American muscle oh yes the
actions kicked up another notch Vin
Diesel fully has superpowers now in the
end they gotta race a plane where they
get Shah but Giselle dies no at least
for now I mean we'll see Dom crashes his
car into the plane epic Wipeout uh don't
worry though he's totally unscathed and
now with full pardons the gang is back
in La for a good old-fashioned Toretto
family Barbecue complete with Coronas
now you never know what the official
title is going to be this one they keep
it simple Fast and Furious 7. turns out
owenshaw survived and he has a brother
Decker jaw played by Jason Statham who's
out for vengeance against our crew over
in Tokyo yeah we're drifting the
timelines finally caught up turns out
the car that killed Han was no random
accident it was Shaw but meanwhile our
crew of super spies is approached by
their new CIA Handler Mr Nobody a real
chill guy who enjoys Coronas they need
to stop a super villain from destroying
the world and for some reason only a
team of precision drivers can do it but
they can't just drive in there so they
have to airdrop their cars out of a
plane skydiving cars the actions kicked
up a notch their first step is to rescue
this hacker Ramsay who joins the crew
and uh tejan Roman both have a huge
crush on her then they head to Dubai for
a Sheik's Chic party because the super
weapons hidden inside this fancy car but
how they gonna get it out of here you
know it they drive the car out the
window then it's the final showdown on
the streets of LA where they got a race
a predator drone but a drone's no match
for a good old American muscle in fact
the tops who saves the day by flexing
out of his cast and crashing an
ambulance into it and by the way this
whole time Shaw was hunting them down so
he's finally caught up to Dom for their
final street fight thing about street
fights
[Music]
Street always wins and so our family of
Street Racers has saved the world once
again and this time Brian O'Connor
retires for good because this is the
movie where Paul Walker died in real
life it's a beautiful send-off as he and
Dom have one final race and as the roads
diverge oh tears everywhere next up it's
Fast and Furious 8 but they've gone nuts
with the official titles again our
gang's on another super spy mission when
wait what's this Toretto goes Rogue he's
working for Charlize Theron because she
has hostage Dom's ex-girlfriend Elena
and her new baby yeah that's Dom's
secret son with dom working for the
enemy our crew needs help so Mr Nobody
brings in Hobbs and Shaw these two start
off as Arch enemies but pretty soon
become best Frenemies and so is Dom
stealing the super weapon for Cipher our
whole Crews teamed up to take him down
but in these movies Vin Diesel has super
powers they all gang together is no
match for him in the final showdown
Cipher hacks a nuclear sub so our gangs
got a racist submarine but who's this
flying in it's Deckard Shaw on a mission
to rescue Dom's baby uh Elena by the way
was killed so now that Dom's son is safe
he joins the fight and a Subs no match
for a good old American Muscle the
actions kicked up another notch epic
explosion but Dom's totally unscathed
now it's time for the spin-off movie
Fast and Furious presents Hobbes and
Shaw it's a standard best friend me
Bromance action comedy where Hobbs and
jaw team up with Shaw's sister Hattie to
stop Idris Elba from destroying the
world it's really not the Fast and
Furious movie except the characters
names and a lot of sweet driving action
and so next up it's Fast and Furious 9
going for minimalism with just F9 Dom
and Letty are retired again living that
parent life with Dom's son Brian but
when Mr nobody's playing a shot down
they gotta jump back in that driver's
seat now Central American militaries are
no match for good old American muscle in
fact the only thing that could match it
is even more American Muscle and the
only thing that could beat this family
is more family cause it's John Cena as
Jacob Toretto Dom's long-lost brother
yes back in the day their dad was a
racer who died in a big car crash when
Dom found out it was Jacob's fault he
challenged him to a brother race loser
is exiled so Jacob Toretto independently
also became a super spy but working for
the bad guys the crashed Mr nobody's
playing to steal some super weapon and
rescue Cipher who's now got that Miley
Cyrus haircut so is Jacob stealing the
other half of the super weapon he's
ziplining out of there but his brother
Dom's hot on his tail and Al gets him
for a big brother fight it's the tech
girl Ramsay who ends up in the driver's
seat and embarrassingly she doesn't know
how to drive they do have a giant magnet
in this truck though so wow him gets
John Cena's car and captures him now
turns out this super weapon had
something to do with their old friend
Han and yes it's happening Han is still
alive turns out Mr Nobody recruited him
a while ago and they used shot coming
after him to fake his death but Shaw by
the way didn't know about this fake
death he thought he killed him for real
and after the credits they meet up
awkward word he's got this kind of
adopted daughter now whose parents were
the scientists that designed the super
weapon and turns out her DNA is the key
so it's the final race against their
armored car where our crews got the
magnets well but Cipher and the bad guy
betrayed Jacob and in the moment Don
saves him so the torretto brothers
working together flip this thing and
save the day but the super weapon's been
uploaded to the cloud they gotta stop
the satellite luckily a satellite's no
match for some good old-fashioned
American Muscle yes tejan Roman strap a
rocket to their car and I kid you not
they blast into space with the action
being constantly kicked up a notch I
mean you knew this was inevitable they
destroyed the satellites and saved the
world but Cipher's coming in to at least
kill Dom but you know the drill epic
Wipeout totally unscathed Jacob Toretto
gets his Redemption he's still very much
a wanted criminal but in a callback too
the original movies Dom gives him the
keys so he can escape and so once again
our crew of Street Racers has saved the
world they celebrate with a good
old-fashioned Toretto barbecue including
Coronas
you like this recap hit that subscribe
button for more of the best Recaps of TV
and movies
[Music]